[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
March 10th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
many Americans will include reservations
at Airbnb properties as part of their
spring and summer travel plans but the
ratings left by previous guests might
not tell the whole story of what to
expect when they walk in the front door
Wall Street Journal travel reporter
Alison Poley looked into this and she
joins me with more hey Allison thanks so
much for being with us thanks for having
me so Allison there are several
companies in the vacation rental space
why are guest reviews particularly
important to Airbnb hosts this is an
extremely competitive environment for
airbnbs and for short-term rentals in
general there are more short-term rental
options and listings than there have
been in Prior years so hosts need to
stand out and one way they can do that
is through the guest rating and that's
the rating that the guest leaves at the
end of their stay where they're talking
about not just their overall experience
but how the host fared on certain
categories such as responsiveness and
cleanliness and how do those ratings
help Airbnb hosts Stand Out Among their
competitors one way it factors in is the
Airbnb algorithm and that determines
which properties are going to show up
when a guest is searching for where to
stay and so super hosts and those are
people who have an overall average of at
least 4.8 Stars they typically earn more
than regular hosts and a lot of times
they show up higher in the algorithm
when a guest has been searching for
example say a guest is searching for a
property with three bedrooms a pool and
a fire pit the listings that come up are
going to depend on a bunch of factors
like what's available the price but also
how responsive the host is the number of
cancellations and the rating that the
host has as well how does a guest rating
affect a host's relationship with Airbnb
the feedback that they get depends on
what their recent ratings are and so we
know that the average rating for homes
in the US on Airbnb was 4.74 stars in
2022 it was pretty much identical in
2021 and 2019 according to a market
research firm called air DNA
but if hosts receive an overall rating
of one to three stars
they're essentially in trouble now
Airbnb says these emails that they'll
send out are automated and they aren't
meant to punish hosts but in reality
they let them know hey your ratings
aren't what they used to be and if you
want to keep your listing active your
ratings have to improve so these emails
will give them
tips they'll give them links to message
boards it will give them detailed
feedback on what guests have been saying
so they can improve their stays but they
make hosts pretty nervous because some
of them say you know if I get a few of
these
one star reviews from people who have an
ax to grind then I'm in trouble okay so
it's really important to the host that
they get a review from a guest that's as
close to five stars as possible if not
five stars yes not just approaching five
stars that is five stars that's what
they all want but of course there are
rules about this from Airbnb so hosts
are not technically allowed to promise
anything in exchange for a five-star
review they're really not supposed to be
messaging people asking for it
specifically or withholding any type of
information or offers for in exchange
for these five star reviews that's not
to say that doesn't happen but
but yes there are rules around the
rating system that are put in place by
Airbnb now you mentioned a moment ago
that the average guest rating is between
4.7 and 4.8 that's pretty close to five
stars wouldn't that be a good rating for
a host essentially if a host is not
getting a five-star review they see it
as a detriment so to have super host
status which is the top of the top tier
hosts need to have an average rating of
4.8 so that means if someone is getting
consistent four stars their overall
rating is going to drop they're in
Jeopardy of losing their super host
status and it's different on other
platforms so airbnb's smaller competitor
verbo to maintain the top status hosts
need to have a 4.3 overall rating or
above as opposed to Airbnb which
requires 4.8 or above all right and so
what's the concern about how a rating
that's close to a five but not quite a
five might be perceived by potential
guests it's not as good as a property
that's getting a 4.9 for example or 4.95
and you're really litigating the
difference between tenths of stars in
this percentage you know these go down
to the decimal point but from a guest
perspective it's also kind of tough to
tell what the difference is between a
4.7 and a 4.8 for example so a lot of
times guests want to be generous and
they think oh I had an amazing time I'll
give five stars or maybe some things
weren't exactly as I thought they should
be but I don't want to put the host out
so I'll give them high five star rating
at the same time there is this pressure
from the host some hosts put up magnets
in their properties explaining the
rating system and saying if you don't
give me five stars I could be in trouble
with the platform so there is this
pressure for guests to some sometimes
inflate their ratings with guests I
spoke to told me oh so there's a
responsibility on the part of the guest
here when it comes to writing up these
reviews guests are part of this yes
ultimately they decide what rating they
want to give and how honest they want to
be at the end of the day so what kind of
research can a guest do to be better
informed when they're planning to make a
reservation if you ask Airbnb they say
most guests leave reviews that are
reflective of their experience and are
truthful
a lot of guests however say that they
feel pressured to leave higher ratings
perhaps than the property deserves so
one thing Travelers can do is read the
reviews very closely and read the
content of in addition to just looking
at the star ratings take a look at what
people wrote and a lot of times you can
see subtle messages about the quality of
the property maybe people are vague
about what they experience but they
might refer to an issue so be on the
lookout for descriptions that might
indicate something went wrong and can
help you learn a little bit more about
where you might be staying alright
that's Wall Street Journal travel
reporter Allison Poley Allison thanks
again for being with us thanks for
having me and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen from The Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
thank you